- [Voiceover] Part c.
A researcher estimates
that in a certain organism,
the complete metabolism or
glucose produces 30 molecules
of ATP for each molecule of glucose.
The energy released from the
total oxidation of glucose
under standard condition is
686 kilocalories per mole.
The energy released from
the hydrolysis of ATP to ADP
and inorganic phosphate
under standard conditions
is 7.3 kilocalories per mole.
Calculate the amount of energy available
from the hydrolysis of 30 moles of ATP.
Calculate the efficiency
of total ATP production
from one mole of glucose in the organism.
Describe what happens to the excess energy
that is released from the
metabolism of glucose.
All right, I'm tired of squeezing things
in between the questions,
so let me go down here
to get some real estate.
So let's do the first part.
Let's calculate the
amount of energy available
from the hydrolysis of 30 moles of ATP.
So let me write this.
Hydrolysis.
Hydrolysis of
30 moles
of ATP.
So I'll draw this, and we've
got the title right over there.
So let's just take 30 moles,
30, 30 moles
of ATP times,
they tell us how much energy is released
when you hydrolyze that ATP per mole.
They say, the energy released
from the hydrolysis of ATP,
let me underline that.
The energy released from
the hydrolysis of ATP to ADP
and inorganic phosphate
under standard conditions
is 7.3 kilocalories per mole.
We have 30 moles,
it's getting hyd, that
is undergoing hydrolysis,
and so 30 moles times 7.3 kilocalories,
kilocalories per mole.
And what is that going to be equal to?
Well the moles cancel with the moles.
The units are going to be kilocalories,
which makes sense, because
I want units of energy.
And what is 30 times 7.3?
See, three times 7.3 would be 21.9,
so this is going to be 219,
since this is 30 times 7.3.
219 kilocalories.
All right.
Now let's do the second part.
I'll do this in a different color.
If you're actually taking the test,
you know I might get the
benefit of multiple colors,
but this is for you, to help me help you
understand what's going on.
Calculate the efficiency
of total ATP production
from one mole of glucose in the organism.
So I'll do that over here.
Efficiency.
Efficiency is,
actually let me do it,
well, efficiency is equal to
energy is going to be energy in ATP,
energy stored
in ATP,
over total energy,
total energy from oxidation,
energy from oxidation
of glucose.
So they say calculate the efficiency
of total AT production, ATP production,
from one mole of glucose in the organism.
So this is going to be equal to.
So they tell us what the energy production
when you oxidize one mole of glucose.
They say it is 686 kilocalories per mole.
So the denominator here
is 686 kilocalories
and the numerator, the
energy stored in ATP,
well, for this particular organism,
it is able to produce 30 ATPs.
The complete metabolism of glucose
produces 30 molecules of ATP.
So for every mole of glucose,
it's producing 30 moles of ATP.
And so we already figured
that's going to be 219 kilocalories.
219 kilocalories.
So now we just have to do
a little bit of math here,
figure out what 219 divided
by 686 is going to be.
Let me do it over here.
686 divided by 200, oh, sorry,
219 divided by 686.
This is going to be less than zero.
So let me go straight to, how many times
would 686 go into 2,190?
Well, this is a little bit less than 700
and seven times three is 21,
so this looks, it's about three times.
Three times six is 18.
Three times eight is 24 plus one is 25.
Three times six is 18 plus two is 20.
Let me subtract it.
Let's see.
90 minus 58 is 32.
So I have 132
Then I can bring down another zero.
686, well, let's see.
It looks like this might
be one or two times.
Let's see, two times 686 would be 1,200,
this is actually going to be one time,
by feeling, or maybe we'll
round up, it sounds like
So one times 686 is 686.
You subtract.
All right, I will do some regrouping here.
So I can make this a 10,
this a one.
So 10 minus six is four.
Now I can make this a two and this an 11.
11 minus eight is three.
And then 12 minus six is six.
So, 686 goes into 6,340,
this is definitely going
to be more than 5 times.
So if we want to approximate,
we would round up.
This is going to be approximate,
so this going to be something else
that is greater than five,
so it's going to be approximately 32%.
So I could write it, let me write it here.
So this is approximately 32% efficiency.
So roughly 32% of the potential energy,
or of all the energy that can be produced
from the oxidation of glucose
actually ends up getting stored in ATP.
Now, they say describe what happens,
I want this in another color for fun.
Describe what happens to the excess energy
that is released from the
metabolism of glucose.
Yeah, what happens to,
what happens to the
other 68% of the energy?
So, I'll do it over here.
The rest of the energy
is released as heat.
The rest of energy
gets converted, or goes,
is released,
released as heat.
And you could say it's
also released as entropy,
increasing the number of
possible states of the cells,
more things are bouncing
around in different ways.
But this is the easiest
way to think about it,
it is released as heat.
In general, when you think
about any thermodynamic process,
if you think about the efficiency,
and you think about,
well, where is all of that
lost energy that wasn't captured,
it's usually going to be,
it's usually going to be heat.
All right, now let's do part d.
Part d.
The enzymes of the Krebs cycle function
in the cytosol of bacteria,
but among eukaryotes,
the enzymes function
mostly in the mitochondria.
All right, mostly in the
mitochondria, an organelle.
Pose a scientific question that connects
the subcellular location of
the enzymes in the Krebs cycle
to the evolution of eukaryotes.
All right, well, we've talked about it,
when we first talk about
mitochondria on Khan Academy,
but there actually is a
theory that mitochondria,
or the ancestors of mitochondria,
might have been independent,
prokaryotic organisms.
So we could say, the scientific question,
we could say, were the
ancestors
of mitochondria,
mitochondria
once independent,
in-de, independent,
independent,
we could even say, well, prokaryotic,
prokaryotic, kary-otic
organisms
whose descendants lived, learned,
whose descendants became incorporated
in euakaryotic organisms?
Whose descendants,
descendants, de,
descend, descendants,
whose descendants
became, became incorporated,
became incorporated, corp-or-ated
inside eukaryotes,
eukaryotes.
So that's a scientific question,
and a really interesting one,
that, you know, if you look at any cell
in the human body,
you're actually going to,
you're going to see these mitochondria,
or actually in the
great majority of cells,
and were their ancestors
once independent organisms
that now have, whose
descendants now live in
symbiosis with our cells
because they're so good
at the Krebs cycle?